wir sind gewillt die bundesregierung
aber auch die bundesländer der deutsche
bundestag alles zu tun was notwendig ist
alles zu tun was deutschland braucht
damit wir durch diese krise möglichst
gut hindurch kommen
das zeichen der deutschen regierung
heute kann man historisch nennen wir
werden helfen gegen die korona folgen
mit krediten ohne obergrenze
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers die welt kämpft an
zwei fronten gegen das corona virus
einmal medizinisch und dann auch mit den
folgen für die wirtschaft und
gesellschaft guten abend in allen zu
einer etwas längeren heute -sendung wir
geben ihnen den überblick über diesen
besonderen nachrichten tag sport mit
kristin otto christin und ohne
bundesliga der komplette spieltag wurde
verschoben später mehr genannt
um was es geht vor welcher
herausforderung wir alle stehen hat der
präsident des robert koch-instituts
heute ganz klar gemacht und damit
beginnen wir heute abend eine situation
wie in italien im moment könne ja auch
für deutschland nicht ausschließen
wir wollen versuchen mit allen uns zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln diese co
wird diese epidemische kurve abzuflachen
die basis breiter zu machen um warum wir
wollen dass eben möglichst viele von den
schwer erkrankten nicht gleichzeitig im
gesundheitssystem auftauchen dort
behandelt werden müssen in
krankenhäusern so medizinischen lage
gleich mehr was das virus mit der
wirtschaft macht ist nicht abzusehen die
folgen werden sehr schwerwiegend sein
das ist jetzt schon klar und die
bundesregierung will gegensteuern mit
hilfen die es so noch nie gegeben hat
gucken wir uns mal die kernpunkte an ein
unbegrenztes kreditprogramm für
betroffene firmen die kredite nicht
zurückzahlen können
dazu steuererleichterungen in
milliardenhöhe weil der staat fällige
steuern stunde und als option könnte
sich der staat auch an strauchelnden
unternehmen beteiligen florian hahn hat
details sie wollen ein starkes signal
aussenden
zwei minister sprachen nicht mit großen
worten das was wir ihnen heute
vorstellen ist eine ist die umfassendste
und wirksamste hilfestellung und
garantie die es jemals in einer krise
gegeben wert legen gleich fertig das mal
so sagen dass alle waffen auf dem tisch
und zeigen dass wir gewissermaßen
stärker sind als das problem dass uns da
ökonomisch begegnen kann nicht nur das
reisen fast völlig zum erliegen gekommen
die lufthansa gibt am nachmittag bekannt
sie wolle mit regierungen über mögliche
staatshilfen sprechen in der korona
krise die längst auch eine
wirtschaftliche ist entscheidet sich die
bundesregierung zu einem historischen
schritt
kein unternehmen soll allein deshalb
pleitegehen kein arbeitsplatz allein
deshalb wegfallen
vor allem setzt man dafür auf kredite
für die betroffenen vom taxifahrer bis
hin zu unternehmen mit einem
jahresumsatz von 2 milliarden euro das
gesamtvolumen unbegrenzt es werde
geklotzt nicht gekleckert
und das können wir auch weil wir in den
letzten jahren unsere möglichkeiten für
eine solide haushaltspolitik genutzt hat
haben und jetzt gewissermaßen auf der
basis der sehr guten sehr stabilen
weltweit vorbildlichen finanzen der
bundesrepublik deutschland alle kraft
haben das notwendige zu tun
am frühen abend auftritt der kanzlerin
auch sie betont erneut man werde alles
tun was notwendig sei
die bundesregierung ist natürlich bereit
wenn sich neue sachverhalte und neue
entwicklungen ergeben auch weiter in
diesem geiste zu agieren und ich möchte
das mit dem wunsch verbinden dass auch
die bürgerinnen und bürger so wie sie es
schon zeit schon tun
solidarität zeigen indem sie abstand
zueinander halten
zur stunde krisensitzung im kanzleramt
die bundesregierung trifft sich mit
vertretern von wirtschaft und
gewerkschaften
es geht um die wirtschaftlichen folgen
von corona darüber sprechen wir noch mit
chakuza banerjee aktuell guten abend
viele superlative die die regierung da
heute in den mund nimmt worte die
bleiben sollen wie viel psychologie ist
dabei sicherlich eine menge wir wissen
ja noch gar nicht wie lange diese krise
dauern wird und wie schlimm sie
tatsächlich wird das kann am ende
niemand sagen das hat die
bundesregierung auch mehrfach betont und
damit kann natürlich auch momentan
niemand sagen ob die opel-hilfen die
jetzt angeboten werden auch reichen
werden
das signal das heute aus gesendet wird
ist allerdings ganz klar ist soll
zuversicht vermitteln und und auch
vertrauen
diese formulierungen die sagen wir tun
das was wir können wir tun alles was wir
können
die sind ganz klar auf die auf die
wirtschaft gerichtet und auf ein wenig
optimismus den man darf verbreiten
möchte
interessant ist auch wie er hat es wurde
ja in der letzten zeit sehr viel in
deutschland darüber gestritten ob geld
da ist und wenn ja wofür da es sich die
bundesregierung offensichtlich einig in
sachen pandemie soll es diese
diskussionen nicht geben
jetzt ist es ja so dass das virus vor
regierungen auch nicht halt macht eine
spanische ministerin hat das virus
kanada das parlament ist im sonderurlaub
wie wird denn die regierungsfähigkeit in
deutschland gesichert
ja da gibt es noch keine einheitliche
offizielle richtlinien dafür
ausschlaggebend sind die empfehlungen
des robert koch institut ist wie auch
für alle anderen menschen in deutschland
momentan sitzt ja die bundeskanzlerin
hier hinter mir im kanzleramt mit
gewerkschaften und wirtschaftsvertretern
zusammen hoffentlich im nötigen abstand
man geht auch kreativ mit dieser krise
um für die nächste woche waren zwei
staatsbesuche hier angesagt bei der
bundeskanzlerin diesen kurzerhand
umfunktioniert worden zu
videokonferenzen die kabinettssitzung am
mittwoch soll nach jetzigem stand ganz
normal stattfinden
aber das ist wie gesagt der stand von
heute das kann sich täglich ändern
ich habe unter vielen dank nach berlin
und wir bleiben noch einen moment bei
den auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft und
gucken auf die die sich jetzt größte
sorgen machen weil sie um ihre existenz
fürchten müssen nils schneider und
carsten behrendt berichten
sämtliche events abgesagt max pohl ist
sein geschäft mit veranstaltungstechnik
weggebrochen spontan bietet er mit
seinen sieben mitarbeitern nun virtuelle
konferenzen per videostream an
selbsthilfe hilfe von außen dringend
nötig das ist im moment müssen wir die
große dürre und da wurde jetzt
angekündigt dass bald das wasser kommt
aber das was er muss auch wirklich weit
kommen vor allen dingen die
zugänglichkeit muss vereinfacht werden
also es darf keine formulare geben oder
großartiges und das muss wirklich
unkomplizierte und schnelle hilfe seien
dann im moment da haben alle genug zu
tun um sich mit anderen sachen noch
auseinander zu setzen
berlin lebt von veranstaltungen
tourismus kultur fast alles geschlossen
und nun soll es auch clubs und kneipen
treffen aber es ist ganz klar noch mal
diese begegnungsmöglichkeiten leider
auch im kulturbereich müssen
eingeschränkt werden berlins legendäre
partys generieren 200 millionen euro
umsatz beschäftigen 9000 menschen 100
sind es im schmutz die mehrzahl
freiberufler viele minijobber
das programm der regierung soll den
kreativen helfen doch der klub chef hat
zweifel kurzfristig gedacht hilft es uns
leider überhaupt nicht weil die
existenzen oft so prekär sind und ich
denke auch an unsere künstlerinnen die
wir dann eben nicht mehr buchen und
bezahlen können dass es oft einfach um
wenige tage sich handelt und die leute
stehen vor der insolvenz drei bis vier
wochen können sie aus eigener kraft
durch halten danach müssten sie die
lichter ausmachen in dem
schwul-lesbischen traditionsklub statt
party muss der chef weiter zum anwalt
ein beratungsgespräch in sachen
insolvenzrecht
und damit sind wir schon beim thema
einschnitte im alltag in den aller
meisten bundesländern machen die schulen
und kitas ab montag zu so sieht die
entscheidungslage im moment aus die
meisten bundesländer schließen ihre
schulen komplett in hessen und sachsen
bleiben sie offen aber es gibt keinen
unterricht mehr
mecklenburg vorpommern will morgen
entscheiden was das jetzt für die
familien bedeutet zeigt petra neubauer
so wird es ab montag fast überall in
deutschland aussehen schulen und kitas
geschlossen vorerst bis zum ende der
osterferien eine drastische maßnahme die
der bayerische ministerpräsident aber
als zwingend nötig erachtet nach aussage
alle belogen können diese fünf wochen
ganz entscheidend sein um eine
entsprechende verlangsamung bei der
studio zu haben
schule zu bedeutet keinesfalls ferien
per internet könnten aufgaben zu den
schülern geschickt und zuhause
bearbeitet werden aber ich glaube dass
die schulen in deutschland da sehr
unterschiedlich aufgestellt sind wir
haben schulen die haben überhaupt kein
wlan wir haben schulen wie hier die sehr
gut ausgestattet sind kein unterricht
dafür selbst online lernen am münchner
luisen gymnasium herrscht weil manche
abiturienten skepsis
die war dass wir überall ein paar teile
wie babys lernen aber dass jetzt auch
schon abgestürzt weil das so überfordert
war das programm ich hätte es eigentlich
besser gefunden wenn das jetzt entweder
früher passiert wäre oder gar nicht weil
jetzt ist es echt doof weil das virus
ältere menschen stärker gefährdet sollen
die großeltern nun keine kinder mehr
betreuen
für eva lia rohr aus münchen eine
hiobsbotschaft die suchtberaterin hat
drei kinder und ein betreuungsproblem
ganz auf die oma zu verzichten wird uns
wahrscheinlich nicht gelingen
ich denke man kann jetzt nur noch von
tag zu tag planen also das wahnsinnig
ungewiss für eltern in so genannten
systemkritischen berufen wie ärzte oder
pflegekräfte hat die bayerische
regierung eine kinderbetreuung im
notfall gruppen angekündigt ob aber auch
eva paar jahre darauf zurückgreifen kann
weil sie im moment noch nicht in
deutschland hat das virus bis jetzt acht
todesopfer gefordert die zahl der
infizierten
bei 3062 das tägliche leben bei uns
ändert sich und das wird sich weiter
ändern es gibt heute neue beschränkungen
es gibt aber auch menschen die gerade
jetzt und aus eigenem antrieb gucken wie
sie in unmittelbarer nachbarschaft
helfen können völker dutschek fasst die
korona lage in deutschland zusammen
polizeikontrolle mit schutzmaske und
fieberthermometer
wer von frankreich ins saarland will der
muss von fall zu fall auch die
temperatur messen lassen dann etwa wenn
der autofahrer über grippesymptome
geklagt hintergrund die französische
grenzregion ihr seit mitte der woche als
risikogebiet eingestellt haben haben wir
ja die situation zu verzeichnen dass
jeden tag 18 tausend pendler kommen
teilweise ungetestet das risiko ist uns
zu groß besuchsverbot für krankenhäuser
pflege und altenheime in nordrhein
westfalen und bayern gelten künftig
verschärfte regeln auch in den heimen
des münchen stift hier leben 2100
patienten die extrem pflegebedürftig
sind
wir wissen natürlich aber auch ist eine
belastung für unsere bewohner seine
belastung für die angehörigen die
natürlich gerne ihre angehörigen
besuchen möchten
aber wir bieten natürlich darum dass
einzuhalten weil wir der festen meinung
center schutz unserer bewohner
bewohnerinnen steht über allem
leere kirchen in vielen gemeinden gibt
es am sonntag keine gottesdienste und
messen
darauf haben sich mehrere evangelische
landeskirchen und katholische bistümer
verständigt auch der zentralrat der
muslime rät von der teilnahme am
freitagsgebet ab bis mindestens ende
märz
nachschub mangeln bei den tafeln 90
prozent weniger dosen und nudeln sammeln
die helfer in marburg ein viele die
sonst spenden haben sich offenbar selbst
bei hamsterkäufen eingedeckt natürlich
kann man sich komplett von solidarität
per internet nachbarschaftshilfe bieten
vor allem jüngere an
hallo liebe nachbarn falls sie in zeiten
von corona unterstützung braucht
einkaufen medikamente sagt uns bescheid
solidarische grüße senden elisabeth und
lea was hilft da sind sich die experten
einig ist das öffentliche leben
herunterzufahren so weit wie möglich
österreich verschärft die regeln im land
restaurants bars und cafés müssen
nachmittags zu machen nicht notwendige
geschäfte schließen komplett im westen
von österreich ist die skisaison vorbei
viel früher als sonst und zwei tiroler
hochburgen stehen komplett unter
quarantäne britta hilpert vom skigebiet
ischgl im paznauntal gibt es nur bilder
vom mittwoch denn ein kamerateam kommt
hier nicht mehr rein oder raus das tal
ist abgesperrt unter quarantäne
ebenso wie st anton am arlberg gäste
müssen zwei wochen da bleiben oder
sofort abreisen ohne zwischenstopp nach
hause es ist die schärfste aller
scharfen maßnahmen der tourismus nation
am sonntag schließen alle skigebiete im
westen corona zwingt die regierung zu
harten einschränkungen es sind maßnahmen
die allerdings notwendig sind damit wir
die ausbreitung des virus in österreich
zumindest verlangsamen
viele treffen vorkehrungen sich für
einige zeit zurück zu ziehen
vorratskäufe obwohl supermärkte und
apotheken keinesfalls geschlossen werden
sollen alles andere dagegen schon
ab montag sollen kaffeehäuser und
restaurants stets um drei uhr
nachmittags schließen läden ohne
lebenswichtigen bedarf dagegen sollen
gar nicht erst öffnen boutiquen besitzer
wie hans kostet nach bereiten sich auf
schlechte zeiten vor
die überlegungen sind jetzt unsere
mitarbeiter bereitzustellen oder zu
entlassen wir also weniger weil wir
nicht wissen wie lange das dauern wird
das leben in österreich wird sich
grundlegend ändern warnt die regierung
zunächst für eine woche gelten die
maßnahmen doch kaum einer hier glaubt
dass es so schnell vorbei ist
in den wiener messe hallen bauen sie nun
ein notlazarett auf und die
flugverbindungen nach frankreich spanien
und in die schweiz wurden heute gekappt
in der korona krise schottet sich
österreich weiter ab so wir müssen jetzt
auch besonders nach spanien gucken wo
die regierung den notstand ausrufen will
spanien hat in europa nach italien die
meisten infektionen und die zahlen nimmt
rasant zu
der regierungschef sagt heute es liegen
harte wochen vor uns und er mobilisiert
jetzt auch die armee in frankreich
wandte sich der präsident an seine
bürger mit einem appell aus paris thomas
walde
der französische präsident appelliert an
die republik man stehe erst am anfang
der epidemie und müsse sie gemeinsam
durchstehen nur so und wir werden sicher
kontrollen einführen müssen grenzen
schließen müssen aber das müssen wir
dann tun wenn es nötig wird und das
müssen wir auf europäischer ebene
europäer richelle robin möglicher
grenzschließungen bisher hat makro das
so nicht gesagt frankreichs regierung
ergreift drastische maßnahmen
sie schränkt das versammlungsrecht ein
sie schließt alle schulen krippen und
universitäten
wir müssen sehen wie unsere arbeitgeber
reagieren wir werden von zu hause
arbeiten müssen damit wir uns um die
kinder kümmern können
im nachbarland spanien steigt derweil
die fallzahl dramatisch 4000 infizierte
120 tote ministerpräsident sanchez
kündigt notmaßnahmen an die alarm
zustand ist ein instrument unseres
rechtsstaates unserer verfassung um
ausserordentlichen krisen
gegenüberzutreten wie wir sie gerade
unglücklicher weise der ganzen welt und
auch in unserem land erledigen
die regierung kann nun militäreinsätzen
und die bewegungsfreiheit einschränken
sie kann wichtige güter rationieren
einige museen wie dem prado in madrid
sind bereits geschlossen
geschäfte schulen universitäten sollen
folgen die tourismusindustrie ist
besonders getroffen es ist zwar sehr
einfach zu sagen dass man das lokal für
ein oder zwei wochen urlaub hat aber
wenn wir in dieser saison die für uns
wichtig es gar keinen umsatz machen dann
haben einige auch trotz der notmaßnahmen
rechnet auch spaniens regierung für die
kommenden wochen mit zahlreichen
weiteren infektionen
der amerikanische präsident stark in der
kritik wegen seines krisenmanagements
will den nationalen notstand ausrufen
und damit hilfen des bundes frei geben
rund 42 milliarden dollar für die am
stärksten von corona betroffenen gebiete
donald trump wird im weißen haus in
einer stunde eine pressekonferenz geben
und am montag will trump an einem krisen
gipfel der wichtigsten industriestaaten
teilnehmen der g7 per video-konferenz
sicherheitshalber der kampf gegen die
pandemie ist eine herausforderung über
alle kontinente und klimazonen hinweg
ganz besonders dort wo es schon unter
normalen umständen kaum eine
funktionierende gesundheitsversorgung
gibt aber auch in einem industrieland
wie italien christoph festival italien
kämpft gegen das virus draußen auf den
straßen fast unheimlich leise
doch hinter den fassaden in den kliniken
mit letzter kraft über 1200 tote fast
18.000 sind infiziert viel zu viel auf
einmal
verzweifelt hatte italien deshalb die
welt um hilfe gerufen und jetzt auch
bekommen ausgerechnet aus china
gesichtsmasken und beatmungsgeräte
schickten die selbst geprüften chinesen
man hilft sich weit über grenzen hinweg
gleichzeitig kämpft jedes land auf seine
art die philippinen etwa zwei fälle gibt
es offiziell
trotzdem wird der öffentliche raum
großflächig desinfiziert manchmal mehr
manchmal wohl weniger sinnvoll auch hier
drängen die eigenen die supermärkte
anderen bleibt nur galgenhumor
panikkäufe wie sollen wir armen denn
panikkäufe machen ohne geld ein ernstes
problem der muslimischen welt am
beispiel indonesien moscheen schließen
ist kaum vorstellbar stattdessen sprühen
sie in massen zwei millionen liter
desinfektion für 10.000 moscheen dazu
der rat an die gläubigen bringen sie
ihre eigene gebets matte mit waschen sie
nach ein paar tagen und dann coruna und
brasilien als hirngespinst hat präsident
personal wo das virus lange verspottet
und sich jetzt vielleicht auf seiner usa
reise selbst angesteckt eine zeitung
berichtet dass offiziell aber gilt nein
eindeutig kann dagegen 1 über brasilien
gesagt werden die zahl der infizierten
wächst gerade trotz oft über 30 grad
hitze scheint dem virus also kaum zu
schaden
es gibt aber auch anzeichen dass sich
das virus zumindest eindämmen lässt und
zwar aus asien wo alles begonnen hat die
chinesische führung sagt man habe das
schlimmste überstanden und fordert den
rest der welt auch von den erfahrungen
chinas im kampf gegen das virus zu
lernen
ein bisschen zuversicht ist zurück in
peking von dort berichtet ulf röller
langsam kommt das leben nach peking
zurück die gemüse märkte sind wieder gut
besucht nach monaten des bangens und der
angst vor dem virus trauen sich die
hauptstädter wieder raus es sind kleine
veränderung die das sichtbar machen vor
mehr als einem monat gab es kaum verkehr
in peking
jetzt sind die straßen voller geworden
ein hauch von alltag
jetzt ist es viel besser früher gab es
fast keine leute jetzt kommen sie zurück
ein bisschen besser ist es schon aber
noch lange nicht so gut wie vor der
epedemie stolz schließt china seine
provisorischen krankenhäuser in woran
die staatspropaganda will zeigen dass
das land sie nicht mehr braucht die zahl
der neuinfizierungen geht wohl
dramatisch zurück heute meldet china nur
acht neue fälle für das ganze land
wir freuen uns dass die patienten
endlich wieder gesund sind
das virus hat aber die wirtschaft chinas
stark geschwächt nun soll sie wieder
angeschmissen werden aus dem ganzen land
machen sich arbeiter in sonderzügen auf
den weg in die fabriken zu anfang werde
der schlüsselindustrien in einer
ordentlichen art und weise in gang
bringen
china löst die selbst auferlegten
fesseln millionen von menschen werden
durch das land reisen und damit gehen
pekings machthaber ein hohes risiko ein
denn die gefahr wächst dass das virus
mitreißt
in one feiern sie die eindämmung des
virus china will unbedingt nach vorne
blicken so mehr zum thema in einem zdf
spezial direkt nach dieser heute
-sendung kohona virus in deutschland die
große unsicherheit und auf dem neuesten
stand bleiben sie auch online natürlich
in einem live blog auf heute de und in
der heute app es gibt krisen auf dieser
welt die angesichts der cholera-epidemie
aus dem blick zu geraten drohen die lage
der flüchtlinge auf den griechischen
inseln etwa mehr als 40.000 unter ihnen
viele kinder zumindest einige von ihnen
aus den lagern herauszuholen haben
deutschland und andere aber längst nicht
alle eu länder versprochen
heute haben die innenminister darüber
beraten wie krüger berichtet aus brüssel
kinder auf lesbos zwei zelte für 40
menschen irgendwo im hinterland keine
dusche keine ärzte und doch lieber das
als maria das offizielle lager steht für
europas scheitern in der
flüchtlingsfrage zugemüllt und überfüllt
minderjährige hier rausholen wenigstens
die die ohne eltern reisen für dieses
ziel wird deutschland in brüssel
mitstreiter und bekommt erstmal absagen
[Musik]
berlins ist auf see op niederlande sind
der meinung wir können alles tun um den
griechen zu helfen
die eu macht das ja auch aber hier
nehmen keine kinder auf knopf steht
begrüßt dass einige länder nun
verantwortung für minderjährige
übernehmen wollen aber wir gehören schon
zu denen die bislang meist zugenommen
haben dass tecan dies sofort mit dabei
sind dann doch acht vielleicht neun
länder von luxemburg bis deutschland und
frankreich die großen nehmen die meisten
auf doch die zahl die auswahl der ablauf
bleiben im konjunktiv ich weiß ja auch
noch einmal dass das nicht der große
wurf ist aber es ist das was machbar
wäre und wo ich auch hoffe dass genug
energie politische energie aufgebracht
wird und einzig aufgebracht wird dass
wir diese kinder nicht können in dieser
situation muss so verhandelt man weiter
für deutschland steht die zahl von 300
menschen im raum 304 aus könnten aus
moriya zum vergleich genauso groß ist
die zahl derer die an einem tag in
deutschland asyl beantragen
jetzt ist es amtlich die mietpreis
bremse wird verlängert bis 2025 und sie
wird verschärft mieter können zu viel
gezahlte miete für zweieinhalb jahre
zurück fordern so hat es der bundesrat
beschlossen
außerdem haben die länder die sogenannte
stiefkindadoption geregelt auch
unverheiratete können jetzt ein kind aus
einer früheren beziehung des partners
adoptieren
in den usa hat ein gericht die frühere
wikileaks informanten chelsea manning
aus der beugehaft entlassen
der richter sieht ihre aussage vor einem
geschworenengericht als nicht mehr
erforderlich an
henning saß seit zehn monaten in haft
weil sie sich weigert gegen wikileaks
gründer julien assange auszusagen
vor der entscheidung so berichten
mannings anwälte hatte die 32 jährige
versucht sich das leben zu nehmen
hunderttausende geheime militärdokumente
hatten hatte manning wikileaks zukommen
lassen vor ihrer beugehaft saß die
whistleblower wenn bereits sieben jahre
den us militär
und damit in dieser heute sendung sind
wir beim sport deutschland ohne
bundesliga schwer vorzustellen aber es
wird jetzt so kommen ich glaube es geht
auch ohne die schönste nebensache der
welt ziemlich kurzfristig vor knapp drei
stunden kam dann doch die entscheidung
der deutschen fußball liga den
bevorstehenden kompletten spieltag der
ersten und zweiten bundesliga zu
verlegen wie hier in düsseldorf soll der
spielbetrieb sogar bis zum 2 april ruhen
so die empfehlung der dfl das soll aber
erst am montag konkretisiert werden
markus haben in frankfurt am main was
tut sich warum tut sich die dfl so
schwer mit diesen entscheidungen
es war eine zähe und nicht unbedingt
überraschende entscheidung der dfl um 10
uhr 20 die zusage für spiele ohne
zuschauer
um viertel nach vier dann doch die
endgültige absage
der druck auf die funktionäre dann wohl
doch zu groß geworden vor allem weil
mehrere spieler auf den sozialen
netzwerken ihren unmut ausgedrückt haben
von affen im zirkus war da die rede oder
von einer unhaltbaren entscheidung der
dfl und als fortuna düsseldorf dann am
nachmittag offiziell angefragt hat das
spiel heute abend abzusagen blieb der
dfl keine andere wahl
und das wohl die richtige entscheidung
markus vielen dank für diese
einschätzung und auch in anderen
europäischen ligen ruht der ball die
premier league posiert vorerst bis
anfang april spiel stopp auch in der
champions und europa league die uefa hat
zunächst alle ansetzungen der kommenden
woche ausgesetzt keiner weiß ob und wann
es weitergeht für frankfurt und
wolfsburg wird er es nach den hinspielen
niederlagen ohnehin schwer
leverkusen könnte mit dem viertelfinale
liebäugeln einen sieg feiern mit den
fans das ist nicht mehr
selbstverständlich die leverkusener
wussten es zu schätzen
ich weiß nicht wer das gesagt hat aber
die sind aber die leute die sind salz in
die suppe und darum schwimmen fußball
für die keine arbeitsstunden in der 37
minute zunächst die pfiffe der glasgow
fans in den ohren elfmeter trotzdem
sicher verwandelt die mitgereisten
bayern-anhänger bekam nach gut einer
stunde einen feinen drop geht von arango
es zu sehen
20 bevor eine viertelstunde vor schluss
dank edmondson auch die mehr als 40.000
ranger fans jubeln durften
doch kurz vor abpfiff stellte bailey auf
321 beste aussichten für das rückspiel
wenn es noch eines gibt entscheidung
auch in der formel 1 die ersten vier wm
rennen sind gestrichen gefahren wird
frühestens ab ende mai und die formel
hat ihre saison für mindestens zwei
monate gestoppt und ich habe tatsächlich
auch noch etwas schönes vom biathlon
wenn auch ohne publikum doppelerfolg für
die deutschen damen beim letzten weltcup
sprint denise herrmann gelingt in
kontiolahti finnland ihr dritter sieg in
diesem winter sie sind sichert sich
damit die kleine kristallkugel
platz zwei geht an teamkollegin
franziska pros und morgen dann noch die
verfolger dann ist auch mit biathlon vor
bei kristin dankeschön so zum schluss
gucken wir noch mal nach italien dieses
großartige land zurzeit eine einzige
sperrzone
[Musik]
siena in der toskana gemeinsam singen in
quarantäne
jeder zu hause und doch alle zusammen
und das ist neapel aus dem
neapolitanischen übersetzt umarme mich
fester italien zeigt wer zusammensinkt
ist weniger allein
großartig gute nachrichten vom wetter
zum wochenende kommt ein hoch das
bedeutet sonne und steigende
temperaturen mehr gleich von katja
oliver sie bleiben rundum informiert bei
uns jetzt gleich im zdf spezial um 22
uhr 10 dann beim kollegen claus kleber
im heute journal
morgen übernimmt hier petra gerster und
die freut sich auf sie von uns allen im
team 19 herzlichen dank für ihr
interesse und in allen einen angenehmen
freitagabend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren jetzt
kommt hoch helge das zieht von heute
abend bis morgen abend hier von
frankreich her weiter in richtung polen
und ostsee
und es bringt sonnenschein mit und auch
wärme morgen gibt es anfänglich noch so
ein bisschen regen im südwesten das tief
ihres das streift wird aber wirklich nur
ganz am rande heute nacht gibt es noch
einige schneeregenschauer im erzgebirge
sonst wird es häufig klar und die
temperaturen sinken im nordwestwind auf
werte zwischen 3 grad am niederrhein und
minus fünf grad in der lüneburger heide
es droht also in ganz deutschland
bodenfrost die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 6 grad in der lausitz
und 12 grad am niederrhein und westlich
des rheins im schwarzwald und am
alpenrand da kann es morgen ein bisschen
regeln richtung nordosten dagegen
strahlt die sonne besonders nordöstlich
der elbe und der winter dann komplett
gedreht er kommt aus südöstlichen
richtungen und sehr schön frühlingshaft
wird dann auch der sonntag bei
temperaturen von 9 bis 16 grad und dann
wird es von tag zu tag immer wärmer am
montag bei neun bis 18 am dienstag bei
10 bis 19 grad
schönen abend noch